Today we're learning English with Disney's
newest movie Cruella. Maybe you remember
watching 101 Dalmatians as a kid or even the
1996 live action movie starring Glenn Close.
Well this time the evil villain is played by the
Oscar-winning actress Emma Stone. Interestingly
Emma stone is an American actress but speaks with
a British accent in this movie. So get ready to
learn about connected speech, some new vocabulary
phrases and more. Because every week we help you
to learn English without getting lost, without
missing the jokes and without subtitles. Just like
Rania who is a new subscriber of only one week and
already says that our channel is by far the best
to learn with on youtube. So to join Rania
and our community of over 4 million learners
hit that subscribe button and the bell down
below so you don't miss any of our new lessons!
How would you like to develop confidence in your
speaking whilst having real-life conversations
at the touch of a button when connecting with
other learners from all around the world?
Sounds like a dream right? Well now with the
RealLife App we've made it a reality. You
can download the app for free and improve your
listening and speaking whenever and wherever you
want. Just click the link in the description
down below or you can simply search for the
RealLife English App in the Google Play or
Apple App Store now. Download it now and
let us guide you beyond the classroom to live
and learn and speak English in the real world!
If you're enjoying this lesson you should check
out this lesson we made with Disney's Cinderella.
I'll link it down in the description box below
so that you can watch it next also don't forget
to give this lesson a like if you haven't already
and subscribe so that you're notified when we have
a new lesson! Now it's time to watch without
subtitles and test your knowledge good luck.